foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
good morning you're watching Sky News
live from Westminster it's 10 o'clock
the major breaking story this morning
the publication of the long-awaited
report into whether Boris Johnson
deliberately misled Parliament over
claims covered rules were broken in
Downing Street the report by MPS on the
Privileges committee has concluded that
the former prime minister committed
repeated contempts of Parliament that
merited a 90-day suspension in response
Mr Johnson has hit back claiming that
the report's conclusion was deranged
let's take you through the main findings
so far well the report concludes that
Boris Johnson deliberately misled the
House of Commons and the Privileges
committee It also says it would have
recommended that Boris Johnson should
have been suspended for 90 days if he
had not already resigned as an MP it
recommends that he should not be granted
a former member this pass for the
Parliamentary estate
the report says that the former PM was
also complicit in a campaign of abuse
and attempted intimidation of the
committee
it also concludes that in deliberately
misleading the house Mr Johnson
committed a serious contempt which is
defined as an obstruction or
interference on the workings of the
commons
well the report was published at nine
o'clock this morning it runs to 30 000
words and 108 pages long
it details the evidence that was
gathered including photos of the events
in question or the MPS on the committee
had provisionally agreed a suspension
long enough to potentially trigger a
by-election in Boris Johnson's
constituency before he resigned in
protest at the findings attacking the
committee as a kangaroo court
well in response today Mr Johnson has
released a lengthy statement let's read
you some of those key excerpts he said
the committee now says that I
deliberately misled the house and at the
moment I spoke I was consciously
concealing from the house my knowledge
of illicit events he says this is
rubbish it is a lie in order to reach
this deranged conclusion the committee
is obliged to say a series of things
that are patently absurd or contradicted
by the facts he went on to say about the
committee's decision
but their arguments can be boiled down
to look at this picture that's Boris
Johnson with a glass in his hand he must
have known that the event was illegal
therefore he lied that is a load of
complete tripe that picture was me in my
place of work trying to encourage and
thank my officials in a way that I
believe was crucial for the government
and for the country as a whole and a way
which I believe to be holy within the
rules
he ends by saying this report is a
charade I was wrong to believe in the
committee or it's good faith the
terrible truth is that it is not I who
has trusted the truth to suit my
purposes it is Harriet Harman and her
committee this is a dreadful day for MPS
and for democracy
this decision means that no MP is free
from vendetta or expulsion on trumped-up
charges by a tiny minority who want to
see him or her gone from the commons
well that lengthy statement from the
former prime minister is in contrast to
Boris Johnson's approach when he was
seen running this morning before the
report's publication when he remained
tight-lift
is this the end Mr Johnson
have you run out of Road
whether you take responsibility for
anything
of your criticism for the committee
backfired
well joining me now is our political
editor Beth Rigby at Beth a 90-day
suspension uh the recommendation that
his house pass is denied these are
serious conclusions for Mr Johnson
whatever he says in his response they
are really serious conclusions and
actually the more that you read through
this document the more you have to think
that part of the severity of the
sanctions were not just the original
moments where he the report complete
concludes deliberately misled Parliament
over what he knew about events in number
10 during lockdowns but how he
subsequently handled uh this
investigation because the committee uh
says explicitly in its conclusions that
he was complicit in the campaign of
abuse and attempted intimidation of the
committee it talks in the report about
the attempts to undermine the legitimacy
of the committee and that this is an
attack on Democracy itself and they have
come out the other end of this very
painful long process 14 months and I
should remind you that this is a
cross-party committee the majority is
conservative MPS it has come out after
this uh tortoise period with a with a
bigger sanction than any of us expected
I think that is fair to say
um there was talk before around the time
of the hearings would they even go to
the 10-day plus recommendation of
suspension because that Jay means that
the Prime Minister the then prime
minister the former prime minister could
have been uh subject to a recall
petition in his constituency that
basically means that if enough
constituents sign it they rerun a
by-election so you can get kicked out of
parliament so there was a question at
the start of all this though would they
have the guts to do that because he is a
former prime minister with a big base
um but they went much further than that
and I think that speaks number one
to the fact that this report in great
detail goes through why the MPS do not
think his arguments are legitimate I
think to the undermining of the
committee that we've talked about but I
I would say one other thing about this
Jane and I think this will now begin to
emerge
by recommending such a stringent
sanction on a former prime minister by
recommending that his pass should be
removed what you can already see now
is that the criticisms that Boris
Johnson laid out very clearly on Friday
when he resigned from uh Parliament
saying that this was or announced his
intention to say it was a kangaroo court
and a political stitch up now they've
said that that's additional contempt of
parliament so that that you know that
has gone against him in terms of the
committee but it has given supporters
something to Rally around uh the the the
committee is overreached and watch for
that in the coming hours the fight back
by Johnson allies okay Beth lots more
from you throughout the morning here on
sky but let's quickly cross to our
Deputy political editor Sam Coates who's
been looking at a bit more forensically
at the report document itself and Sam
what can you tell us
so here it is Jane it's 108 pages and
it's absolutely damning let's take you
through first of all some of the
conclusions now the committee which has
been sitting for you know almost a year
Gathering evidence taking visits uh and
then holding those explosive series
um starts its Report with its
conclusions now it says that Boris
Johnson repeatedly and continually
denied the facts for example his refusal
to accept there were insufficient
efforts to enforce social distancing at
Gatherings
um they say another thing that they can
have concluded is that he closed his
mind to facts that were so obvious that
the only conclusion that could be drawn
was that he was deliberately closing
them and closing his mind I think it's
quite hard to call him a liar
these sorts of statements are an attempt
to to get as close as they can within
parliamentary language they say that
Boris Johnson sought to rewrite the
meaning of the rules and guidance to fit
his own evidence so for example at one
point he said that some of the
conditions in some of the parties and
events were imperfect but that wasn't a
breach of the rule they say well it was
and they also said that Boris Johnson is
the master of after the event
rationalizations uh and the example
there uh is that uh for instance when he
said he was baffled as to why he found
uh why he got a fixed penalty notice uh
they say that's quite instructive they
conclude we came to the view that some
of Mr Johnson's denials and explanations
were so disingenuous that by their very
nature they were deliberate attempts to
mislead the committee and the house uh
and that is one of the reasons why here
in the com in the conclusion in the
summary they decide that they are going
to recommend that unprecedented sanction
90 days for repeated contempts of
parliament for deliberately misleading
the house deliberately misleading the
committee breaching the confidence by
leaking the report imputing the
committee and being complicit in a
campaign of abuse and attempted
intimidation of the committee and that
he should now be removed of his past now
it's interesting just to go through some
of the detailed bits we delve a little
bit detail into some of the some of the
areas that are the naughtiest and and
most instructive
um in this whole Affair so um it's
spending some time on one particular
event that's the Lee Kane and Dominic
Cummings leaving do on the 13th of
November now as one of the ones that
we've got a photo for of Boris Johnson
uh raising a glass in front of a table
of bottles of wine that's his director
of communications and his de facto chief
of staff and they say
uh this Boris Johnson argued that this
was legitimate because both of these
individuals after a fairly accurate his
period were leaving and it was important
for him to be there and give reassurance
it was necessary uh for me to steady uh
the ship now first of all they conclude
after a visit uh that actually no social
distancing was observed as something
that Boris Johnson admitted was
imperfect but didn't see uh as a breach
but really here this is a good example
of the whole approach of the committee
because what they say is that the reason
that they come down against the former
prime minister is because they don't
believe that if there was one of those
press conferences that we saw during the
coronavirus pandemic and he was asked at
those whether leaving dues to maintain
staff morale were permitted under the
rules and guidance in Force at the time
they do not believe the Tory dominated
committee do not believe that he would
advise the British public that it was
okay and it's that charge of hypocrisy
and as they they call it post facto
justification in other words as it were
coming up with a new argument after the
event that they come back to time and
time and again in this report as you can
see here's another one you will remember
the number of times that Boris Johnson
said that he was repeatedly assured by
officials that the events that are being
talked about didn't breach the rules so
the committee did a deep dive they went
into quite some detail about why they
thought about whether or not that claim
was two it was true and what they find
is that Boris Johnson actually got
advice not from lawyers but from two
figures both in the Press office who
were not lawyers he said their views
were good enough to uh to perfectly
possible for those two uh to look at to
consult lawyers but they were the only
two people that he spoke to he did not
speak to the cabinet secretary Simon K
Simon case told this inquiry that he
didn't give him any kind of assurance
that all the events were legal and
critically look at this it's in the
middle of your screen right now Boris
Johnson was asked well did anyone or
anyone else did any other official give
you advice saying that all these
gatherings were legal and he said
um uh well maybe one advisor I can think
of who's asked me not to be named and
then and then his lawyers Boris
Johnson's lawyers wrote to the committee
after uh that Sensational hearing a few
months back
um and says on reflection Mr Johnson is
still not sure if these matters and
doesn't wish to speculate so just just
pause for a moment Boris Johnson
repeatedly told the committee
that he was repeatedly told that the
Gatherings were legal and yet when asked
by who it was a couple of press officers
and it was maybe twice so repeatedly on
this occasion means two uh means
probably no more than two uh and so uh
he uh the committee say you might have
thought that the Prime Minister when
challenged on this at Prime Minister's
questions was reflecting a civil service
view that it was all fine in fact there
was just based on a couple of press
lines to take didn't emanate from anyone
senior didn't come from lawyers and they
think uh that that is a problem uh and
that uh his attack his attempt to claim
uh act premises questions to MPS uh that
um it was all fine uh and that it was
based on a significant reassurance just
simply isn't true
um that's the kind of tenor of the
report
um you have all the way through this
um example after example uh of um the
MPS going into detail uh and um finding
that Boris Johnson um and effectively
his justifications are limited at what
he is doing uh he's um they feel quite
clearly a multiple breach of the rule
you can see the photos we've seen them
before that's the party that I was just
talking about the Glee Kane Dominic
Cummings leaving do a lot of commentary
a lot of the response from Boris Johnson
will be about how thi thinks that this
kind of gathering is okay you heard from
his statement he was just trying to
reassure staff one of the big
conclusions from this report is there
was no justification no justification
for these kinds of events and he
wouldn't advise the public to do so if
it was about anyone else that is at the
heart of why Boris Johnson today would
have got a 90-day suspension as it is
he's quit as an MP he's launched a
furious exorcet against the committee
for this but they say there is no
justification for events like that and
he wouldn't have said so to any other
member of the public
Sam thank you very much
well back in March Boris Johnson gave
evidence to the Privileges committee and
in a grueling six
six uh let's have a bit of a reminder of
some of those key moments
I'm here to say to you hand on heart
that I did not lie to the house but it
never occurred to me or I think the
current prime minister at the time that
the event was not in compliance with the
rules that the press conferences over
this period you regularly repeated the
phrase
hands face space so there can be no
doubt that you understood what the
guidance and rules meant and were
intended to to achieve yes or no yes
thank you
the question is uh whether what you said
about this particular way of thanking
yourself in the House of Commons was
strictly accurate the guidance does not
say uh you can have a thank you party I
I believed that this event was uh not
only reasonably necessary but it was
essential for work purposes but another
witness State stated that they couldn't
get through the room to leave because
people were standing four to five people
deep is there any reason why we should
disbelieve that people who say that we
were partying in lockdown simply do not
know what they are talking about so why
did you tell the household guidance was
followed completely in number 10. nobody
came to me and said uh we've got a
problem with this one did any government
law officer or any member of the
government legal department did anyone
of those give you the Assurance the
short answer is no they didn't we would
be entitled to be a bit dismayed about
the flimsy nature of this assurance when
we took it at face value that these
assurances amounted to something and it
looks from what you've told us in answer
to Mr coss's questions that they did not
amount to much at all
well a reaction is coming in all the
time Esther McVeigh MP has just tweeted
she says the demands calling for Boris
Johnson to be denied a former MPS Pastor
parliament are absolutely absurd and
utterly unnecessary well join me now is
Brendan Clark Smith conservative at MP
for Basset law and I imagine that you
would possibly Echo what Esther McVeigh
says um you're a supporter of Boris
Johnson throughout this you're in the
minority there aren't you I don't
believe I am certainly the members I've
spoken to certainly people in my
constituency think this is a massive
overreach here we think he's been
treated very very unfairly from the
start now I haven't said too much I've
waited for the report to come out I
think you have to do that and you have
to treat the committee with respect and
to be able to do its conclusions without
being interfered with but now I've read
them uh really I I think people's worst
fears have been confirmed there and
Boris Johnson quite rightly as had a
rebuttal of many of those things now
obviously they must have some kind of
crystal ball and see into people's minds
and what they knowingly did but this
90-day suspension and taking somebody's
pass off though and now any reasonable
person can think that that's an
acceptable punishment I don't know Jane
well well that's partly we understand
heightened because the fact that he
breached the committee's
confidentiality by releasing a press
release on Friday night when he wasn't
meant to so fundamentally he he appears
to have shown a certain amount of
disregard and contempt for the committee
which they they have spelled out
this was was a system that that he
created he's been hoisted with his own
petard here hasn't he well I think in
terms of confidentiality I think most of
us have been getting a running
commentary of what's been going on
because the times has been putting it
over Twitter most of the time so in
terms of wherever this has come from it
certainly hasn't been Boris Johnson uh I
know if I had had these allegations
leveled at me I'd want to defend myself
Boris Johnson's issued a very lengthy
statement now where he's gone into quite
specific detail about a lot of things
and I think he's right to do that but of
course he's he doesn't feel he's been
fairly treated and I think when people
pre-judge you look at the former chair
had to recuse himself quite rightly uh
In fairness from being on the committee
and then has been replaced by somebody
who is again prejudged made comments in
advance now you would not accept that in
a court of law and it's all to do with
due process and fairness that's what the
public wants to see and I don't think we
see that here
this committee essentially found that
not it's not that Boris broke the rules
Boris Johnson broke the rules in in
having these events it's that he came to
Parliament he knew he'd broke the rules
he'd asked his uh colleagues if he'd
broken the rules they said we think you
have broke the rules don't say you
haven't in Parliament and he still went
ahead and said so in Parliament it's
lying to Parliament that's fundamentally
it's showing disregard for the
Democratic structure of our country
Boris was very clear in the evidence he
got that he was giving that statement
with the information that had been
provided to him now when I was a
minister I would have statements
prepared for me I'd read them off and if
you make a mistake or the information is
wrong sometimes you will come back to
the house and you will correct that and
Boris Johnson did that when he was made
aware that there were things going on
but he wasn't particularly but he said
that he then lied again to them as a
committee
well I I think that's a little unfair
really I mean Boris Johnson again he's
given a a very open account of himself
he's given a very detailed account of
what he's actually done there and really
they've got no evidence at all or proof
that he knowingly misled the house and I
think this is a very very unfair on
Boris Johnson but I think it also has
some quite serious consequences for the
rest of us as Member of Parliament now I
feel very very uneasy with MPS removing
other MPS or having that decision we are
put there by the electorate by the
people of this country and yes we do
have to maintain maintain standards but
we should not have people going after
people that they don't like having
opinions on them and being able to
remove them from the House of Commons
and I think that is very very wrong
opinions they don't like they say he
lied and voters want MPS especially MPS
who are the prime minister to tell the
truth
well absolutely and as Boris Johnson has
said he believed with what he was saying
was was the case at the time and when he
found out that some of that information
was wrong he went and corrected that now
what you've also got is uh various
arguments that overreach for example
things concerned with the Metropolitan
Police uh it's very clear what the the
law actually is there was only one
incident where a fine was issued there
if I'm honest I don't think I'd have
accepted a final many of my constituents
would with that but the Prime Minister
put his uh at the time put his hands up
as did the current prime minister I
thought again that was very unfair that
fine that was there and that was the
only thing that is mentioned I think
it's gone far beyond that remit where
it's actually almost interpreting and
making up the law itself as to what they
think the or should be and now of course
there are questions arising about other
people's conduct as well now I would
hope I wouldn't make any conclusions
about that at all until they've had a
fair hearing they've been listened to
and I won't pre-judge them on that
unfortunately that's not a courtesy
that's been extended by Johnson
you say that you don't think you're in
the minority in terms of coming here to
defend him and support him uh but but
from those we've spoken to it appears
the majority of conservative MPS largely
want him to shut up I mean we will find
out next week when when this report has
presented to the house and MPS get an
opportunity to vote on it what what the
majority of conservatives do think but
do you accept that he is still damaging
the conservative party well I wouldn't
have had this in the first place I think
it's wasted a lot of parliamentary time
I think we could be getting on with a
legislative agenda and a lot more
important things that are going on there
and people want to see an end to it and
I completely get that and we've had a
we've had a very difficult year the
Poland is very difficult and divided
parties don't win elections so I do hope
that we're able to come together and put
this behind us but before then I think
there's some unfinished business and
listen he's dealing with on Monday
Bernie Clark Smith we appreciate you
coming in and talking to us thank you
well uh it has been a fascinating hour
or so here in Westminster we're going to
get lots more reaction to this report
from the Privileges committee into Boris
Johnson's conduct today with Sky News
for all the latest on this breaking
story
[Music]
I'm Mark Stone and I'm Sky's
correspondent based here in Washington
DC
well the plan seems to be to head to the
police station where the policeman who
fired the shots was based
they know his memories memories gone
[Music]
in almost every corner this town has
been completely destroyed by the fire
I've witnessed the remarkable passion
for politics here but the anger too we
have to get Trump out of the White House
is this the moment to reform gun laws
you know it's it's easy to go to
politics but it's important it's at the
heart of the issue I get that that's
where the media likes to go it's not
it's where many of the people we've
talked to here like to go I report on
the biggest stories from around the
world
[Music]
town that is effectively encircled
you say it's all fabrication what's
happening in butcher
destroyed my nation
[Music]
to the heart of stories that shape our
planet
a very violent series of confrontations
here what do you think of Isis anybody
here know the truth of Isis
foreign
[Music]
welcome back we're discussing the major
breaking news story this morning the
publication of the long-awaited report
into where the Boris Johnson
deliberately misled Parliament over
claims covert rules were broken in
Downing Street well the report by MPS on
the Privileges committee has concluded
that the former prime minister committed
committed repeated contempt of
Parliament that merited a 90-day
suspension while our Deputy political
editor Sam Coates has been taking a
closer look at the report document
itself Sam what can you bring us so you
heard the main charges by the committee
a few moments ago one of the interesting
things was in that main report it said
that there were 16 new events in number
10 and checkers that they didn't know
about before that they'd been told about
by government lawyers that were
potentially problematic Boris Johnson
denied that they were a problem but they
couldn't investigate they didn't have
time but potentially would have resulted
in more sanctions for Boris Johnson and
now it turns out there is more new
information not just new information
there's a second report that actually is
linked to by the first report additional
material not previously published which
was relied upon by the committee now
we're just starting to go through this
second document and I've just got time
to bring you one thing from it we're
going to go for those with it enjoying
it on page nine let's have a look at
this this is the testimony of a junior
official in number 10.
um I was the now they've blacked out who
exactly it was
um uh and they worked effects actively
in the Press office and the political
advisor's office and there was a vestibu
connecting all three rooms together they
said that they started in 2018. now back
in 2018 in number 10 they used to have a
thing called Wine Time Fridays they were
calendared weekly events in our Outlook
Diaries starting at 4pm where the Press
officers would gather on a Friday to
have drinks during the pandemic number
10 despite setting the rules to the
country was slow to enforce any rules in
the building that's a sensational
sentence so here we have a junior
whistleblower saying that number 10 was
telling the country to do one thing and
inside number 10 they were doing
something else the Press officer press
office Wine Time Fridays continued
throughout social distancing was not in
force and mask wearing was not enforced
I once inquired to some of these names
being redacted in March 2020 so about
six weeks into the pandemic four to six
weeks into the pandemic
um to somebody who wasn't named whether
we should be wearing masks and was told
that these science advice that there was
no point and that very little effect it
would have the very little effect on the
spread on covid at that point by the way
I think that's probably a little bit
that's probably quite uh it was probably
quite widespread
um uh all of this was part of however of
a wider culture of not adhering uh to
any rules number 10 was like an island
oasis of normality operational notes
were sent out from the security team to
be mindful of cameras outside the door
not to go out in groups and social data
it was all a pantomime so Sky News would
be standing outside number 10 uh in full
you know obeying the rules talking about
the rules in um and talking about
everywhere else in the country inside
they were not adhering to the rules and
just told be careful when you go out the
door then there's a really interesting
bit at the end birthday parties leaving
parties and end of week Gatherings all
continued as normal those responsible
for the leadership in number 10 failed
to keep it a safe space and should have
set the rules from the start that these
gatherings should not continue it was
only more than a year into the pandemic
that number 10 set up a one-way system
and desk divider sections that's
incredible that's a junior whistleblower
for the first time saying there was
absolute free-for-all in number 10 and
there was only an instruction make sure
when you go out the front door if the
cameras are there to look like you're
social distancing that is damning Jane
Sam thanks very much
um we've got plenty more on this
breaking news after the break I'm going
to talk to a representative of the night
time Industries who says workers in his
sector will be outraged by the report's
findings we're putting those points that
Sam's just raised to him as well
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
welcome back to the breaking news the
publication of the long-awaited report
into whether Boris Johnson deliberately
misled Parliament over claims that
covert rules were broken in Downing
Street well the report by MPS on the
Privileges committee has concluded that
the former prime minister committed
repeated contempts of Parliament that
merited a 90-day suspension in response
Mr Johnson hit back claiming the
report's conclusion was deranged let's
take you through its main findings while
the report concluded that Boris Johnson
deliberately misled the House of Commons
and the Privileges committee It also
says that it would have recommended that
Boris Johnson should have been suspended
for 90 days if he had not already
resigned as an MP it recommends that he
should not be granted a former member's
pass for the Parliamentary estate
the report says the former PM was also
complicit in a campaign of abuse and
attempted intimidation of the committee
and also concludes that in deliberately
misleading the house Mr Johnson
committed a serious contempt which is
defined as an obstruction or
interference in the workings of the
commons
while the report was published this
morning at nine o'clock it runs thirty
thousand words and is 108 pages long it
details the evidence that was gathered
including photos of the events in
question the MPS on the committee had
provisionally agreed a suspension long
enough to potentially trigger a
by-election in Boris Johnson's
constituency before he resigned in
protest at the findings attacking the
committee as a kangaroo court
well in response Mr Johnson has released
a lengthy statement let's read you some
of those key exerts he says the
committee now says I deliberately misled
the house and at the moment I spoke I
was consciously concealing from the
house my knowledge of illicit events
this is rubbish it is a lie in order to
reach this deranged conclusion the
committee is obliged to say a series of
things that are patently absurd or
contradicted by the facts he went on to
say about the committee's decision that
their argument can be boiled down to
look at this picture that's Boris
Johnson with a glass in his hand he must
have known that the event was illegal
therefore he lied that is a load of
complete tripe that picture was me in my
place of work trying to encourage and
thank my officials in a way that I
believed was crucial for the government
and for the country as a whole and in a
way which I believe to be wholly within
the rules Ends by saying this report is
a charade I was wrong to believe in the
committee or its good faith the terrible
truth is that it is not I who has
Twisted the truth to suit my purposes it
is Harriet Harman and her committee this
is a dreadful day for MPS and for
democracy this decision means that no MP
is free from vendetta or expulsion on
trumped-up charges by a tiny minority
who want to see him or her gone from the
commons
or Boris Johnson uh statement is pretty
lengthy those were some of those key
exerts
well let's uh bring in
um Joe here who's joined us in the
studio I mean Joe a 90-day suspension it
is is reading between the lines that the
the supposition that they were going to
give them a big suspension but that that
suspension has got even bigger since his
action on Friday
it's not clear but if you look at what
they are uh giving him the suspension
proposed suspension for it does include
uh a claim by the committee that he was
complicit in a campaign of abuse and
attempts intimidation of the committee
that he's impugned the committee as well
as you say deliberately misleading it of
course 90 days is twice as long as his
trust was prime minister this is
certainly longer than anyone had
expected and there were some members of
the committee who wanted to go yet
further to expel Boris Johnson from The
Commons both Alan doran's the snp-mp and
Yvonne volvaga the labor party voted for
that the full conservatives opposed it
Harriet Harman didn't vote because as
chair of the committee she only votes if
there is a tie what I think the
committee are trying to do because this
is an unprecedented situation is set a
precedent so in future politicians in
particular senior politicians are very
careful about what they say in
Parliament and of course about
correcting the record of what they have
said in Parliament basically a warning
shot here I think for senior politicians
they make it very clear that it's not
just that anyone has said this it's that
the guy in the top job at an incredibly
tense fraught time uh on an issue which
really mattered not just to Parliament
but to uh but to the uh the country
and ultimately the committee Jane are
saying they don't believe that Boris
Johnson's defense is credible they don't
believe it is credible to say as he did
um that some of these events were about
maintaining morale for for staff they
said he effectively knew the rules it's
highly unlikely that he genuinely
believed what he said to the house now
as you know Boris Johnson in that
incredibly long statement about four
pages in my printout
um is very angry
um the anger very clear he ends by
saying for the Privileges committee to
use its prerogatives in this
anti-democratic way to bring about what
is intended to be the final knife thrust
in a protracted political assassination
that is beneath contempt ultimately
though it's his success there who will
have to pick up the pieces you've
already seen in your interview with
Brendan Clark Smith that Boris Johnson
does have some support on the
conservative back benches Mr Clark Smith
saying this is massive overreach by
committee and the next hour or so we're
expecting Penny Morton the leader of the
house to set out a business statement
and which will include we think some
plans for there to be next week a vote
on this will Parliament approve this
will there be a motion for them to
approve this and of course it's sort of
Irrelevant in the sense that Boris
Johnson has has left Parliament the
suspension is relevant the ban on the
pass of course it is still significant
but could we next week see those splits
those divisions in the Conservative
Party come to the fore again and what
will that mean for Mr sunax leadership
when he wants to move on from all of
this of course Joe thanks very much
well of course a thousand s of
hospitality and entertainment workers
across the country were among those
whose professional and personal lives
were severely affected by the lockdown
rules during the pandemic let's talk now
to Michael kill Who's chief executive of
the nighttime Industries Association uh
just interest Michael to get your
reaction to this report it's been pretty
damning about the former prime minister
what do you make of it
well to hear the news today we'll we'll
incite a level of outrage and anger
amongst many across our sector in
particular but also across a wider UK
particularly the thousands of people
who've lost loved ones and the many that
have suffered irrepairable Financial
damage through debt on top of the deeper
long-lasting mental health impact that
thousands of these people are suffering
still today so very very difficult to
digest very very difficult to hear
what are the kind of tales that you hear
from from those who did abide by the
rules who looked at the letter of the
law and said you know we've been told by
the government we we must follow it what
kind of impact did it have on many
people that you represent
well we've heard stories of people
losing not only their business but their
their uh their homes you know everything
that they've they've literally worked to
oh
oh sorry about that we've got a few
technical difficulties with Michael kill
we're going to try and reestablish that
uh link but in the meantime let's just
remind you of some of the details about
the report now it's been published uh
let's just uh go back over how we got to
this point over the last few months well
the Privileges committee was asked to
investigate Boris Johnson in April 2022
over whether he'd deliberately misled
the House of Commons over what he knew
about lockdown parties in Downing Street
in March this year the former prime
minister gave evidence to the committee
where he repeated his defense that he
did not knowingly lie to the house
last Thursday the findings from the
committee's report were sent to Boris
Johnson then on Friday evening in an
unexpected turn Boris Johnson resigned
as an MP with immediate effect and in a
thousand word statement released
alongside that announcement the former
prime minister dismissed the report
describing the Privileges committee as a
kangaroo court and then yesterday the
committee signed off the report ahead of
its release this morning on a deputy
political editor Sam Coates has been
taking a closer look at the report
document itself and so I'm just we're
just talking to the nighttime uh
Industries there and you were just
pointing out in your last little session
that the rules about social distancing
and there was lots of people in perhaps
officers had to uh heed where desks were
taped off and people had barriers put up
those weren't being followed inside
number 10 according to this report no
that's right that extraordinary
testimony that we heard from a junior
official inside number 10 who said that
it was anything goes inside but they
were told make sure you obeyed the rules
if you walked through the big famous
black door of number 10 and came out in
front of the cameras Sky News BBC uh the
ITV all lined up as long as you were
behaving the rules in front of the
cameras much less it would seem
important what was going on behind that
big black door of course officials
working on the covered response of
course it was one of the busier offices
in the country but nevertheless not
social distance saying anything like
what was expected of everywhere else in
the country that's the accusation from a
junior official who has basically been a
bit of a whistleblower inside number 10
and that test to me Jane is interesting
because it falls apart something a
little bit bigger where the committee
are trying to unpick specific assertions
to Parliament by Boris Johnson and uh I
think it's just worth going through one
of those now Boris Johnson argued to the
committee and does publicly and does to
this day that no one raised any concerns
with him he said that he does not this
is during the evidence that he gave
remember being specifically assured by
any senior civil servants about the
rules or guidance within number 10 and
nobody gave me any country advice that
the Gatherings weren't okay
um nobody came to him and said look
we've got a problem with this one you
might need to worry about it so what the
committee has done is it's gone through
a native specific instances where it
basically is suggesting that that's not
quite right in response to this argument
of Silence the committee note that the
senior official all you'll remember
Martin Reynolds who sent out the
infamous party invitation did directly
question with Mr Johnson whether the
guidance had been followed at all times
so there was a question now
um uh Martin Reynolds recently recently
last few days received an honor of
course from Boris Johnson his resonation
honors uh I actually said that after
that discussion he concluded that the
rules were being followed but
nevertheless there was a discussion then
other number 10 uh officials including
senior advisors DD Express concerns here
we've got one from a director of
communications Lee Kane he gave evidence
to the committee uh that when he saw the
email invitation uh he saw it clearly as
a social breach or other other whatsapps
clearly the committee don't believe
Boris Johnson was never warned okay Sam
thanks very much all right we think
we've reestablished connections let's go
back to Michael kill the chief executive
of the nighttime Industries Association
and Michael just wanted to put it to you
you know some things that Sam was
talking about there the fact that the
social distancing that lots of companies
were having to abide by wasn't actually
happening inside number 10 it seems
what's your reaction to that
well it's it's a travesty I mean if you
hear the stories the the work that had
to be done within some of these premises
the spend that was undertaken care
evidence to a point
where they could just barely operate to
cover costs I mean it's devastating to
hear this news to adhere to these
metrics that they set out themselves
um was not and in terms of our industry
they are going to be devastated and they
are going to be looking to government to
to wrong this repairable right uh moving
forward I appreciate that the prime
minister at the moment wants to leave
this behind but this is you know way too
big a void an issue that that has been
presented here that needs to be
addressed
like to the prime minister to do how
could the current prime minister address
this
well we've been um for a long time now
pushing towards
um some uh specific tax cuts that we've
been asking for we missed them in spring
in terms of the budget but we are
advocating for a vat cup in the coming
Autumn budget and we are going to be
pushing hard alongside a huge range of
associations from the industry and many
of the businesses just to be able to
gain that Financial Headroom to survive
this isn't a moment of profit this is a
moment of survival with industrial
action with all of the challenges that
we've faced including cost inflation I
think the government with this news owes
us that to move things forward
Boris Johnson's Defenders though say
that that he's been unfairly treated
we're getting a response from his
supporters all the time they say that
this committee has has massively
overreached its remit he himself says
it's a shrad the conclusions are
deranged and the charges are trumped up
what do you make of that
well we always go back to a really
simple thing there is no smoke without
fire
um as you can understand
um we are relying on the committee uh to
investigate thoroughly and be
transparent in the same way that we're
looking for the covert inquiry to do a
similar thing over a longer course of
time so for us uh as you can appreciate
the news that's come out today and the
the findings from the report are
devastating we'll be a way to hear more
of the detail as we move forward but the
covert inquiry will also address this
and I'm sure we'll come forward with
with relevant initial findings and
information not only in terms of future
proofing ourselves but also the mistakes
and challenges that we've faced but it's
hugely concerning to hear this initial
Report with regard to the prime minister
or former prime minister and his
position on this it's definitely not
instilling us with confidence
a wide
you know I'm interested in I think a lot
of people's habits have changed as a
result of covert as well being all
separated uh and in separate flats and
homes for such a long period of time
seems to have certainly dented a lot of
people's appetite to go out and and
enjoy themselves in large groups do you
think the nighttime industry will ever
truly recover do you think we will get
back to to
how things used to be
well we saw in a report early part of
this year we've lost billions of pounds
worth of Revenue not only to the
pandemic and the challenges we've faced
there but the the double dip in terms of
the cost inflation crisis and also
industrial action has had a huge hit
because of consumer Mobility so for us
we've had you know some quite clear cut
identifiable challenges as we reopened
out the back end of the pandemic we saw
a real drive for people to return to
physical experiences particularly the
social and cultural experiences that we
represent but as you can understand as
they start to feel the pinch in terms of
the inflationary pressures we are
starting to see
ease now and what we have an issue with
is we're being squeezed between the
increase in Opera amount as readily in
terms of the frequency of visit dwell
time and spend so where we are at the
moment is a very compromised position
and we're heavily relying on government
to consider this moving forward given
things like the energy cost which we're
starting to see here but are nowhere
near the position that we need them to
be so that we can sustain this operating
period up until the Autumn budget which
we're hoping to have something off the
back of
Michael Kill from the nighttime industry
uh organization really good to talk to
you thank you for joining us today
thank you
well this is Sky News today and coming
up we're going to get more reaction to
the Privileges committee's report which
concludes that Boris Johnson lives to
Parliament repeatedly over parties that
broke covert lockdown rules and we're
going to be talking to a representative
of the covid-19 bereaved families for
justice group next
[Music]
I'm Mark Stone and I'm Sky's
correspondent based here in Washington
DC
well the plan seems to be to head to the
police station where the policeman who
fired the shots was based
[Music]
the thing you know his memories
in almost every corner this town has
been completely destroyed by the fire
I've witnessed the remarkable passion
for politics here but the anger too we
have to get Trump out of the White House
is this the moment to reform gun laws
you know it's it's easy to go to
politics but it's important it's at the
heart of the issue I get that that's
where the media likes to go it's not
it's where many of the people we've
talked to here like to go I report on
the biggest stories from around the
world
this is a town that is effectively
encircled by the Russians
you say it's all fabrication what's
happening in butcher
destroyed my nation
[Music]
we take you to the heart of stories that
shape our planet
come on yeah I can hear now quite a few
explosions in the distance here in
Jerusalem a very violent series of
confrontations here what do you think of
Isis anybody here know the truth of Isis
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
Fly Emirates fly better
well lots of reaction coming into us on
the Privileges committee report which
has concluded that Boris Johnson did lie
to Parliament and to the committee
itself we've heard from labor in the
last few minutes sang Nam Debonair who
is Labor's Shadow leader of the House of
Commons has made a comment she says that
the evidence in this report is damning
that the conclusions the committee came
to are clear Boris Johnson is a law
breaker and a liar Rishi sunak must now
confirm the government will follow
precedent and give the house the
opportunity to approve the report and
endorse its sanctions in full she goes
on to say Rishi sinak's weakness means
he's never stood up to Boris Johnson
this report makes it even more
inconceivable that the Prime Minister
approved Boris Johnson's resignation
honors list just a week ago as part of
some sort of grubby deal rather than
waiting for this report and saying no to
his boss it is quite a lengthy statement
Rishi sunak she says is so out of touch
he thought it was right that taxpayers
hard-earned money fund Boris Johnson's
ongoing lies to the public it's not
clear in this statement but we think
that's referring to the legal defense
that he was gifted by the government for
the Committee hearing but the statement
goes on to say given the findings of the
committee original should demand Boris
Johnson pays back every penny and labor
say well Richie sudanek is distracted
with the ongoing Tory soap opera people
are crying out for leadership on the
issues that matter to them it's time for
a fresh start with a mission-led labor
government and a prime minister of
Integrity in kierstama who will out
working people first so um labor clearly
making as much of it as they can Let's
cross though to Susie Crozier flinton
who's a member of the covid-19 bereaved
families for justice group and she joins
me now very good to talk to you today uh
what are your thoughts today on hearing
this response from the Privileges
committee
I think I think it's overwhelmingly
unsurprising this is nothing that we
didn't already know
um I think the most shocking thing is is
the flagrant disregard that Johnson is
showing towards the Privileges committee
um the the sort of attack on on
Democracy that seems to be going on but
no I'm I'm not surprised by anything
that the committee has found because I
already knew
um we saw the photographs we heard him
lying to Parliament we already
of the evidence in front of us for him
to try and deny it is absolutely risible
um and also you know particularly
shocking is a statement from
um the second report where there's
talking about
um not adhering to the rules inside
number 10 but making sure they pretend
they are when they're our cameras
present
um I mean this is this is someone who is
supposed to hold the highest honor in
the land who is embarking upon
completely self-serving Behavior at the
expense of Our Lives essentially
I mean when we when we look at how Boris
Johnson handled covid he he was a man
who was very very ill himself he you
know he was in a perilous situation in
hospital so a lot of people will say
he knew what a lot of families you know
like yourselves were going through he
was there at the sharp end he he felt it
he was just doing what he thought was
right
well if that is the case then you should
have demonstrated a lot more empathy if
he was so ill that he almost died as he
claims then surely he understood just
how severe this virus was and is and
just exactly what the risks were around
you know having indoor Gatherings and
being in close contact and sharing
breathing space and all that sort of
thing he should have understood from a
very deeply personal level just exactly
what a danger there was
um so I'm afraid I don't I don't hold
truck with any argument because he
almost died that informed his decision
because actually if he was as ill as he
says he was then he should have made
better decisions to keep people safe
knowing how dangerous
and how threatening the virus is
um and it sounds to me like more Johnson
obfuscation
do you holding truck with with the
thoughts as well that people may say
well you know they may have been doing
something wrong inside number 10 they
may have not been you know abiding by
the rules but overall the rules that
they implemented and the introduction of
the vaccines were effective some would
argue
um and and by you know that are almost
that is the bigger thing that is the
more important thing what do you make of
that
um I think the point is that you know by
March 2020 we'd already seen across the
world the effects of the virus we had
those Dreadful scenes from Spain from
the care homes in Spain
um you know as well as news coming out
of China and other countries so you know
the fact of the matter is that we didn't
do enough we didn't do it quickly enough
and any other arguments you know that
okay vaccine roll out yes that was
absolutely fantastic it's utterly
amazing and but actually there were
measures that we could have put in place
a lot earlier and a lot harder that we
just simply didn't do and the vaccine is
like one weapon in Your Arsenal there
are other weapons in Your Arsenal that
you can employ in order to fight off
through the end it was the virus and
they just weren't employed or deployed
efficiently we're gonna have to leave it
there suzia Crozier flinton very good to
talk to you thank you for joining us
thank you
[Music]
foreign
this is Sky News today it's 11 o'clock
these are our headlines a scathing
report by MPS concludes Boris Johnson
deliberately misled